(laughing) - Today marks the start of
Hispanic Heritage Month.
So what does this month mean to y'all?
- Means we get to celebrate.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- It means we get to show respect
and honor people and
talk about our history
and our culture, and
maybe have some good food,
from what I hear, today
especially, we might do that later.
And you know, it's a moment to like,
look at where we're from,
look at what we're proud of.
- I think the same.
- Yeah, you too?
- Yeah, I think the same.
Family, time.
You need like time for you.
Like, Hispanic's everything.
I think it's everything.
Good food, good moments.
Celebrate every day.
It's our day.
- Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
- Oh, I love you.
Yeah, that sounds fun.
(laughter)
That sounds awesome.
- Your type of party.
- Yeah. - Your type of party.
- I was like, well,
that just sounded great.